the aftermath of the worst floods to hit
western europe in a generation
the german military trying to clear some
of the devastation left in the wake of
the sweeping water
in the town of avila it came up so
quickly people were scrambling to get to
safety
it's unbelievable because i heard a
strange
noise and i was opening the front door
and then the water was coming from
everywhere and i just
pressed hard pushed hard to close the
door and i needed the help of my son and
together we could
close the door but from everywhere the
water was coming in
there's so many tragedies so many lives
which are gone now and they're still
searching for people and that's so
dramatic
homes and businesses built over a
lifetime destroyed
i think it will take months or years to
to
put all so look at the street
it takes a year to
[Music]
i cannot say anything in the belgian
town of pepinster
residents return to their flooded homes
trying to salvage some of their
possessions
but it's the lives locks that hurt the
most and hundreds are still missing
their fate more uncertain with every
passing hour
meteorologists say some areas of western
europe had two months rain in the two
days ahead of the floods with more than
150 liters per square meter falling over
24 hours in parts of western germany
as the clean-up and rescue efforts
continue thousands have now been left
homeless
milan vassilinovic sky news